hey guys it's max welcome to my ultimate
camera comparison testing out the brand
new iphone 12
pro the 11 pro max and the iphone 10
s and we're gonna find out is there
really that big of a difference
between these last few generations now
i'm shooting using the front-facing
cameras and i've been switching between
the audio
so have you guys been able to tell a
difference in the microphone quality
let me know down below and how does the
stabilization work
as i am walking now with that i'm
shooting at 60 frames per second
and both the 12 and 11 pro can shoot 4k
60 whereas the 10s that can only do
1080p
if you want that 60 fps and here's 4k 30
with all three phones can you guys see a
difference in quality or dynamic range
let me know let's start out with a shot
of my dog he looks great in all of them
but what you'll notice is the iphone 10s
could not do a portrait shot from this
distance now we're gonna start out with
early morning shots and then end with
nighttime shots where we're gonna have
some shocking results
but here they look surprisingly similar
you should see a little bit more pop in
the highlights with the iphone 12
pro now cropping in here you'll notice
once again
whites pop a lot more but it's also
cleaner at the same time
with 10 times zoom i'm noticing that the
11 pro kind of struggles with white
balance so you can see in the cityscape
and then when we punch in we don't have
that much more detail with the 12 pro
compared to even the 10s
but what really stands out is how that
white building
pops once again and we have a little bit
more contrast we see the same thing with
this street yes it is already snowing
here
the white balance is great on the 12 pro
we do have some extra
details and slightly better highlights
taking a selfie in difficult lighting
you can see that the white balance is
spot on
and i have a lot more detail in my face
due to deep fusion
and then shooting against the sky with
that smart hdr3
really helped over here where you can
see most of the clouds are still
there compared to being blown out on the
other two now that upgraded smart hdr
doesn't always help you
this was a tough mixed lighting scene
and they look surprisingly similar
now one thing that i noticed is that the
12 pro could take a portrait mode
even if you're very close to your
subject whereas the 11 pro and 10s
can't and at the same time if you're far
from your subject
you can actually use the wide camera and
still get a portrait shot with the 12
pro
whereas the 11 it won't let you you have
to get closer
and of course the 10s you don't have
that ability going down to the parking
garage i took the selfie and the 12 pro
looks so much
better i'm sharp my face is
detailed and the sign in the background
is also being
kept much more so than the other two and
if you look at the jacket
we have a lot of noise in the 10s and
the 11 pro
this is smart hdr and diffusion working
together
on the 12 pro but when you're in a
situation where you don't have crazy
dynamic range
and it is a little bit too dark for
diffusion the 12 pro and 11 pro look
almost the same and of course the 10s
well that telephoto is nowhere near as
good and it looks pretty bad
going outside let's jump into video
quality and
surprisingly it looks very similar even
going back two years to the iphone
10s now as we start walking you'll
notice
some differences the 11 pro and 12 match
up very similarly
but the 10s stabilization is really poor
and we're also blowing out some of the
snow in the highlights
and if you're somebody that runs with
your camera maybe chasing your kid
well take a look at that that
stabilization is
pretty horrendous and this is 10 times
zoom and i'm walking and surprisingly
the pros do great
the 10s not only does it look super soft
and artifact-y
it's super shaky as well switching back
to photo
and a results flip the 10s actually
looks better
than the 11 pro because it's missing all
of those artifacts that are in the image
and i've seen this consistently with 11
pro
the new 12 pro well it takes the best of
both worlds
no artifacts and nice detail
unfortunately we don't always get extra
detail from the 12
pro here it's very bright outside and
the images look very similar other than
white balance the same thing goes for
this ultra wide shot where the 12 pro
nails the white balance and thankfully
the ultra wide lens actually makes use
of diffusion much more often than the
standard
now here i'm standing under a bridge so
it is darker
and that's when the front-facing camera
actually makes use of deep fusion
and it looks great but unfortunately
dynamic range really hasn't improved in
these extreme
scenarios and if you're getting hit with
the sun
quite a bit diffusion doesn't work
because it's ultra bright
and i actually prefer the 11 pros photo
here other than the flaring
it looks like apple is really
controlling their flaring on the 12 pro
where the sun spot is
we're really you know getting rid of
those rays and then the reflection at
the bottom
left hand side is pretty much gone other
than one sunspot which is
awesome we also have better contrast and
white balance now once again if we're
shooting indirect sun
the differences are very minimal even
for portrait mode shots if it's ultra
bright like this
and honestly i prefer the 10s photo here
and then looking at more standard photos
and really good lighting
there is very little difference other
than the 12 pro
you know making the highlights a little
bit brighter so you can see in different
scenes
we're going from a little darker
exposure to 11 pro getting a little
brighter
and 12 pro they keep just kicking that
brightness up
and taking a look at the panoramas
honestly there is no difference between
the last few years
now let's talk about edge detection
which the iphones were not very good at
and thankfully the 12 pro is a lot
better if we look at the 10s and 11
pro next to the neck there's issues
where the arms on the statue is there's
a bunch of issues and the 12
pro nails it here the same thing goes
with this sign there's a bunch of edge
issues here
including the pole in the background
just clearly shows up and wasn't erased
on the two
on the right hand side whereas the 12
pro gets rid of that
and everything is much cleaner and in
this very difficult shot we have the
opposite effect the 10s and 11 pro
get rid of that antler in different
spots and really mess up on some of the
edges
where the 12 pro was smart enough to
keep that all
focused i was really surprised by that
so maybe that is that lidar sensor
now thankfully the ultrawide has gotten
a little bit sharper because it was too
soft before but that's only in photos in
video mode
you don't get any benefits of deep
fusion it is what it is basically
now as far as slow motion it is also
very difficult to see the difference
even going back to the iphone 10s
now one thing i did notice is if you're
shooting 4k 60
the iphone 10s blows out highlights
whereas the other two maintain it
shooting some backlit portraits i was
really hoping that we'd get benefits of
deep fusion here because it was a little
bit darker but nope
we don't and in fact i like the iphone
10s
photo the best same thing goes for the
selfie
it was just a little bit too bright for
d fusion to kick
in now one huge difference is that the
iphone 10s
has a lens that is not very wide for the
selfie camera so sorry emily
you didn't get to make the shot there
whereas the other two
can go wider and you can fit more people
in now if you're somebody who takes
macro photos the iphone 11 pro can't get
as close
as the other two the 10s looks good but
it's not as detailed as the 12 pro
as the sun started to go down i took a
few more portrait shots
and the iphone 10s once again doesn't
let you take wide portraits
which was perfect for this location but
the 12 pro and 11 pro look
almost identical here and switching to
the telephoto lens
the 11 pro looks the best to me it looks
slightly more detailed
so once again the 12 pro didn't kick
into diffusion it was still
a little bit too bright now as the sun
is setting here
the 12 pro photo looks fantastic
not only do we have this beautiful
looking sky but
we also have the proper white balance
the snow still pops compared to the 10s
which looks very flat and we have a nice
mixture of contrast so the image just
looks
awesome and then for some final sunset
shots
once again at 12 pro nails that white
balance
and we have nice contrast in colors the
11 pro doesn't look bad
a little bit too blue and the 10s it
just doesn't look great and then you
don't have this ultra white as well
i went back to that alley because i was
hoping for a night mode portrait shot
there
but those lights above were a little bit
too bright so the 12 and 11 pro look
almost identical
and the 10s well i couldn't shoot
portrait mode there
and here is where the magic happens for
the 12
pro and that is night mode with the
ultra wide
the 11 pro it doesn't look good not a
lot of detail the 12 pro looks
so much better once again taking a
darker shot here you guys see a massive
difference when you're shooting with the
ultra wide
look at this church shot we go from gray
flat
soft to a nice nighttime shot that's
bright and detailed
flipping to the front of the church that
is a huge difference
and i would previously not want to use
the ultrawide camera
because everything's just mushy like the
shot in the snow with these trees
compared to nice detailed shots and then
going into a restaurant
once again if the darker the situation
is the better and the bigger of a
difference we get here
and in this bathroom shot you guys once
again just see how big of a difference
it is
not only in the brightness of the image
the contrast but also the colors
and the ultrawide has less distortion
now on the 12
pro now believe it or not this food shot
was taken in very low lighting and the
12 pro makes it look
fantastic we're once again seeing that
excellent white balance
the extra brightness of the exposure and
the d fusion helping out with extra
details
now here's a very difficult shot the 10s
has lots of noise and it has a blown out
picture in the background
the 11 pro completely misses focus
whereas the 12 pro looks like a nice
combination of both with a lot less
noise now focusing is a really strong
suit of the 12 pro
here's a video where the 12 pro probably
without lidar
isn't having any issues and really dark
lighting the 10s
nothing's happening it's just way too
dark and the 11 pro is just struggling
with that autofocus and when it gets
dark enough
we can use portrait mode with night mode
on the 12 pro
and that's how we get this excellent
dslr looking image the colors are great
the detail is great
very little noise whereas the 10s we
can't even do portrait shots
at the 1x the standard wide lens and
then
in extreme darkness well with the 10s we
have to use
flash and it looks unnatural looks
really bad
11 pro it allows you to do it but look
how terrible that looks
so much noise in the face and the 12 pro
wow that image looks like it was taken
in the daytime
no noise beautiful image lots of detail
all right guys thank you for watching my
ultimate camera comparison between the
10s
the 11 pro and the 12 pro was there a
big enough difference over the last
couple of years to get you to update
and was there anything that really stood
out to you that really surprised you
either in photo or in video let me know
down in the comment section below
make sure you guys click that circle
above to subscribe because we are gonna
have more great iphone videos we're
gonna have the
12 pro review coming up tomorrow you
guys don't want to miss out on that
and you guys can see some other great
videos right over there this one max and
i'll catch you
in the next video
you